Elias stopped eating meat when he was three or four. His mom can't remember-- it's been so long. He was seven when I talked to her. And he doesn't think that anybody else should  eat meat either. And he freaks out. He cried and pleaded at his grandmother's at New Year's when he heard that she might cook brisket, until she offered not to. There was the time that he got so upset in a restaurant smelling the meat cooking in the kitchen and seeing all the people around them eat their meals that he had to go sit up front by the door.
埃利亚斯三四岁时就停止吃肉了。他妈妈记不清具体时间了——那已经是太久以前的事了。我采访她时，他七岁。他认为其他人也不应该吃肉。他会抓狂。新年在他奶奶家时，他听说奶奶可能要煮牛胸肉，就哭闹哀求，直到奶奶答应不煮为止。还有一次在餐厅里，他闻到厨房里烹饪肉食的味道，看到周围的人都在用餐，感到非常难过，不得不跑去门口坐着。
And it kills him especially to think that his little brother might still be eating animals. His brother, Theo, he just turned five at the time of this interview and emphatically is not a vegetarian. What a surprise, two brothers. Their mom, Rachel, says that Theo is not asking to eat meat in front of Elias. He's not asking to eat it all that often.
最让他难受的是，想到他弟弟可能还在吃动物。他的弟弟西奥在这次采访时刚满五岁，而且明确表示自己不是素食主义者。真让人惊讶，两个亲兄弟。他们的妈妈蕾切尔说，西奥不会当着埃利亚斯的面要求吃肉。他也不会那么频繁地要求吃肉。
He wants to eat meat sometimes. And I think he feels it's not fair that Elias-- he calls him the god of food, and that Elias doesn't have the right to be the god of food and tell Theo what to do. It causes a lot of conflict, and I think there are conversations almost every single day around this.
他有时想吃肉。我觉得他认为埃利亚斯这样不公平——他称埃利亚斯为“食物之神”，认为埃利亚斯没有权利成为“食物之神”并指挥西奥该做什么。这导致了很多冲突，我想几乎每天都会围绕这个问题产生争论。
She recorded one of those conversations for us when she was taking Theo, the meat eater, to a party. There was going to be food at the party, and his brother was going to be there, the god of food. What would Theo eat?
有一次，她带西奥这个“食肉者”去参加聚会时，帮我们录下了其中一次对话。聚会上会有食物，而他的哥哥——那个“食物之神”也会在场。西奥该吃什么呢？
So Theo, we're going to this potluck. What do you think's going to be there?
西奥，我们要去参加这个聚餐。你觉得那里会有什么？
Well, I hope there's meat. And if you give me meat, just let me eat it.
嗯，我希望有肉。如果你们给我肉，就让我吃吧。
So what do you think would happen if you ate meat at the potluck?
那你觉得如果你在聚餐上吃肉会发生什么？
Well, we would-- Elias would fight.
嗯，我们会……埃利亚斯会打架的。
You and Elias would fight?
你和埃利亚斯会打架？
Yeah. Well, that would be bad. But I don't know what's going to happen.
对。嗯，那会很糟糕。但我不知道会发生什么。
Well do you think it's-- tonight is a night for Elias' class. Do you think you could not eat meat tonight so he doesn't have to freak out in front of all of his friends? What do you think?
嗯，你觉得——今晚是埃利亚斯的课程时间。你觉得今晚能不能别吃肉，这样他就不必在朋友们面前抓狂了？你觉得呢？
No. I want to eat some because he always says don't eat any meat for the rest of your life.
不行。我想吃一点，因为他总是说这辈子都不许吃肉。
I know. I think things will change when he gets older. But I just want you to think about whether or not you think it's worth it for him to scream and yell at school tonight with all of his friends, OK? Think about that, OK? Deal?
我知道。我想等他长大些情况会有所改变。但我只是想让你考虑一下，你觉得让他今晚在学校当着朋友们的面大喊大叫值得吗，好吗？想想看，好吗？成交？
But when he's not looking, I'll eat some.
但当他不注意的时候，我会吃一点。
When he's not looking?
当他不注意的时候？
Yeah.
是的。
Hmm.
嗯。
Do you think this gives Elias too much power over Theo?
你认为这是否让埃利亚斯对西奥拥有了太大的权力？
Yeah. I mean, it's definitely a concern. And at some point, probably a year into his vegetarianism, he asked that we wouldn't be eating meat either and that the house wouldn't have any meat. And that was something that my husband and I had to take a step back and think about.
是的。我的意思是，这绝对是一个令人担忧的问题。在他吃素大概一年的时候，他要求我们也别吃肉，家里也不要有任何肉食。这是我和我丈夫不得不退一步去深思的问题。
And people would say to us, how could you have your seven-year-old making decisions about how you're going to be running your family? And I guess our response has always been, you have to hear how our child talks about meat and how it feels to him when he sees us eat meat and other people around him and his close family eating meat, it's such a painful experience for him.
人们会问我们，怎么能让一个七岁的孩子决定你们家庭的生活方式？我想我们的回答一直是，你必须听到我们的孩子是如何谈论肉食的，当他看到我们吃肉，看到他身边的人和亲人吃肉时，他内心是多么痛苦。
OK, I just want to say before we go any further, if you are hearing all this and you're feeling judgy about these parents-- and I know you are because that is a national pastime, judging other people's parenting-- I just want to say, I totally felt that way until I heard Elias, just like she says. And hearing Elias made me realize, oh right, she actually is in a really tough situation where she has these two kids, and they both have really strong feelings about this. And she doesn't want to crush either one of them. Anyway, listen. Here's Rachel with Elias.
好的，在继续之前，我只想说，如果你听到这些并对这些父母感到评判——我知道你肯定会，因为评判别人的育儿方式是全国性的消遣——我只想说，在听到埃利亚斯说话之前，我完全也是这种感觉。正如她所说，听到埃利亚斯的话让我意识到，噢，确实，她其实处于一个非常艰难的境地，她有两个孩子，他们对这件事都有非常强烈的感受。她不想伤害他们中的任何一个。总之，听听吧。这是蕾切尔和埃利亚斯。
What made you decide to become a vegetarian? Do you remember?
你还记得是什么让你决定成为素食者的吗？
Yep. And so basically, I just always thought that how they got meat was finding dead animals, like on the side of the road or something. But then I figured out, they're actually killing them. And I thought it wasn't that nice. So I stopped eating it.
记得。基本上，我一直以为肉是捡来的死动物，比如在路边捡的之类的。但后来我发现，他们实际上是在杀害它们。我觉得那不太好。所以我不再吃肉了。
What do you think about other people eating meat?
你对其他人吃肉有什么看法？
I really don't like it.
我真的很不喜欢。
And what do you say about what you want to do with your life? Like, what's your goal in life? One of your goals. I know you have lots of them.
关于你的人生目标，你是怎么说的？比如，你的人生目标是什么？我知道你有很多目标。
To get everybody vegetarian.
让所有人都变成素食主义者。
And what do you feel about animals?
你对动物有什么感觉？
I feel like, well--
我觉得，嗯……
Do you like them?
你喜欢它们吗？
Yeah, I love animals. And I know that there are only, like, 1,000 giant pandas left in the world. And also 30 Amur leopards, so they're pretty endangered.
是的，我爱动物。我知道世界上只剩下大约1000只大熊猫了。还有30只东北豹，它们濒临灭绝。
What do you think about the way people treat animals in general?
你觉得人们对待动物的方式总体如何？
Well, most of them not very nice. Like, think about lambs. They get killed for nothing.
嗯，大多数人对它们不太好。比如，想想羊羔。它们被无缘无故地杀害了。
Every time you talk about that, you start to cry, huh?
每次你谈到这个，你都会哭，是吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Lambs in particular are hard for you, huh?
尤其是羊羔让你很难受，对吧？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Yeah.
是的。
The family did stop eating meat at home after Elias asked. Though Rachel says that they actually didn't eat much meat before that either. Maybe once a week they'd have fish or turkey. And for now, she and her husband's strategy with her two boys is that they try to get them to talk to each other and see each other's point of view, crossing their fingers that in the long run that's going to be best for both of them.
在埃利亚斯提出要求后，家里确实停止了吃肉。尽管蕾切尔说，在此之前他们其实也没怎么吃肉。也许一周吃一次鱼或火鸡。目前，她和丈夫对待两个儿子的策略是，试着让他们互相交谈，理解对方的观点，并祈祷长远来看这对他们俩都是最好的。
In the short run, though, it is complicated. You know, for any parent, there are always some things that you let go in the short run because you cannot fight every fight. And for a while, Theo, the one who eats meat, was secretly going out and getting turkey sandwiches with his dad after soccer. They would even dance this little turkey dance when they did it.
不过从短期来看，这很复杂。你知道，对于任何父母来说，短期内总有一些事情你会选择妥协，因为你不可能打赢每一场仗。有段时间，吃肉的西奥会瞒着埃利亚斯，在踢完足球后和爸爸去吃火鸡三明治。他们甚至在吃的时候还会跳一段小小的“火鸡舞”。
Or here's Rachel with Theo, the meat eater, on a Thursday. Friday, the boys' school serves pizza, and you can get plain or pepperoni. And of course, Elias does not like it if Theo eats the pepperoni.
或者这是蕾切尔和吃肉的西奥在周四的对话。周五，孩子们的学校供应披萨，可以选择纯奶酪或者腊肠披萨。当然，如果西奥吃腊肠，埃利亚斯会很不高兴。
What do you think's going to happen tomorrow about the pepperoni pizza?
你觉得明天吃腊肠披萨会发生什么？
Well, since we don't have lunch at the same time, he will ask me. And I'll just lie and say I got peanut putter and jelly, or any other snacks.
嗯，因为我们吃午餐的时间不一样，他会问我。我会撒个谎说我吃了花生酱果酱三明治，或者其他零食。
OK. Think it's going to work?
好的。你觉得这管用吗？
I don't know. It will be a hard choice to do peanut butter and jelly or cheese.
我不知道。要在花生酱果酱和奶酪之间做选择会很难。
But what are  you really going to do?
但你到底打算怎么做？
Pepperoni.
吃腊肠披萨。
So is it OK for your five-year-old to tell you they're going to deal with the situation just by lying to their siblings?
那么，让你五岁的孩子说他们打算通过欺骗兄弟来处理这种情况，这真的好吗？
Well, I will say that we have come some way since that was taped. And we don't lie about it anymore. And that was sort of, I think, an interim fix.
嗯，我会说自那次录音以来我们已经有所改进了。我们不再对此撒谎了。我想那只是一种权宜之计。
What made him stop lying?
是什么让他停止撒谎的？
I think probably the more we are talking about it, the more I realize it didn't feel great. And so I was sort of being more open with Elias and saying, you have to realize that this is the reality of who Theo is and who he has the right to be. And Theo has his own choices, and he has the right to those choices, even though for you this doesn't make any sense right now.
我想大概是我们谈论得越多，我就越意识到那种感觉并不好。所以我开始对埃利亚斯更加坦诚，告诉他，你必须意识到这就是西奥的现实，这就是他作为个体有权成为的样子。西奥有自己的选择，他有权做出这些选择，尽管这在现在的你看来完全无法理解。
One of the things you recorded was a conversation where you're talking to him about whether Theo has the right to do this.
你录下的其中一件事是关于你和他谈论西奥是否有权这样做。
Can you tell me a little bit about what happens with you and Theo, like when he wants to eat meat and you don't want him to, and the pepperoni whole thing that happens every Friday?
能跟我说说你和西奥之间发生的事情吗，比如当他想吃肉而你不想让他吃的时候，还有每个周五发生的腊肠披萨事件？
I normally kick him in the butt and yell at him a lot.
我通常会踢他的屁股，然后对他大吼大叫。
Literally, you kick him in the butt?
真的，你踢他屁股？
Yeah.
是的。
Hmm. Do you think that makes him want to eat meat less?
嗯。你觉得那样做会让他减少吃肉的念头吗？
No.
不会。
Or do you think maybe the opposite?
还是你觉得可能恰恰相反？
Opposite, probably.
大概恰恰相反。
And what do you think about when we talk about that you can't control other people and what they eat?
当你谈到你无法控制别人吃什么时，你是怎么想的？
What do you mean by that?
你这话是什么意思？
That it's not your job to tell other people what to do about what they get to eat, right? We've talked about that.
意思是告诉别人该吃什么不是你的工作，对吧？我们讨论过这个问题。
Right.
对。
Do you think it's true that you don't have a right to tell other people what to do?
你觉得“你无权告诉别人该做什么”这句话是真的吗？
Yeah, I guess.
嗯，我想是吧。
You guess? But it's hard?
你“想”是？但很难做到，对吧？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
I feel like when he says that, he's not totally sure he believes it yet.
我觉得当他说这句话时，他还不完全确定自己是否真的相信这一点。
No. [LAUGHS] I agree.
没错。[笑]我同意。
You can hear in his voice, like, I know that this is the right thing to say--
你可以从他的声音中听出来，就像是，我知道这是正确的话——
Exactly.
完全正确。
--but this can't be the truth, can it?
——但这不可能是事实，对吧？
Exactly. Yeah.
完全正确。是的。
OK, an important fact-- Theo is not being crushed by Elias' demands. If anything, between the two of them, Theo is the dominant brother in most situations. He's outgoing, he's funny, he's a big personality in whatever room he walks into, and he gets his way with Elias all the time. Like, for instance, when the family took this day trip to visit Rachel's mom and coincidentally it happened to be the day of a herring run, which comes once a year. And so they stopped at this herring ladder, whatever that is.
好的，一个重要的事实是——西奥并没有被埃利亚斯的要求压垮。如果非要说的话，在他们两人之间，西奥在大多数情况下是占主导地位的弟弟。他性格外向、幽默，无论走进哪个房间都个性十足，而且他总是能按自己的方式对待埃利亚斯。比如，有一次全家去探望蕾切尔的母亲，恰逢一年一度的鲱鱼洄游日。于是他们停在那个鲱鱼梯旁，不管那是什么。
We are cheering for the herring, and they're doing their final leap into the water to go back to their spawning grounds. And we finally leave. We go back to my mother's house. And Theo runs to the refrigerator, opens the door, pulls out the jar of herring, and goes, mm, I can't wait to eat that herring. And it was just like, wow.
我们在为鲱鱼加油，它们正做着最后的一跃跳入水中回到产卵地。我们最终离开了。回到我母亲家。西奥跑到冰箱前，打开门，拿出那罐鲱鱼，说，嗯，我等不及要吃这鲱鱼了。当时就感觉，哇。
And of course, there then became Elias, you know, pleading and crying and hoping and hoping that Theo wasn't going to eat those herring, that we just saw all of his cousins.
当然，接着埃利亚斯就开始了，你知道，哀求、哭泣，希望着西奥不要吃那些鲱鱼，那些我们刚见过所有同类的鲱鱼。
Did he eat the herring?
他吃了吗？
Oh, yes. So he ate the herring out on the porch. Elias, I think, cried in the living room.
噢，吃了。他在走廊上吃了那些鲱鱼。我想，埃利亚斯在客厅里哭了。
Elias, however, is always coming up with new tactics. Like in the car recently, he made this proposal to Theo involving matchbox cars, and Rachel flipped on the recorder.
不过，埃利亚斯总是想出新的战术。比如最近在车里，他向西奥提出了一个关于火柴盒小汽车的提议，蕾切尔打开了录音机。
So tell me what you were just saying, that Elias, you had a plan. What was the plan? You said, Theo, if you-- what?
告诉我是怎么回事，埃利亚斯，你有一个计划。计划是什么？你说，西奥，如果你……什么？
Be a vegetarian for two weeks, I'll get you three new cars.
如果你当两周素食者，我就给你三辆新车。
Yay.
耶。
And what do you have to say?
那你怎么说？
Thank oo.
谢谢。
No, but does that seem like a fair deal? If you were a vegetarian for three weeks, you'd get three cars?
不，但这听起来公平吗？如果你当三周素食者，你能得到三辆车？
Two.
两周。
Two weeks. Is it worth it to you?
两周。这对你来说值得吗？
Is that true, Mama? Will he really give me--
那是真的吗，妈妈？他真的会给我……
Yes.
是的。
This is not my negotiations.
这不是我的谈判。
Yes, I will. If you do it for three weeks, I'll give you eight.
是的，我会给。如果你坚持三周，我给你八辆。
What will you give me if I  do it one week?
如果我坚持一周，你会给我什么？
So this is where they are now. Rachel and her husband insert themselves in the middle of these negotiations, or they get dragged into the middle between the two boys. As parents, they have to ad-hoc their way through each new thing the boys come up with on this. Like here with this matchbox deal, the boys could not agree on what is a critical part of any negotiation, of any contract, and that is the start date of the deal. Would their deal begin before or after Friday's pepperoni pizza day at school?
这就是他们目前的情况。蕾切尔和丈夫介入这些谈判中，或者被拖进两个儿子之间。作为父母，他们必须针对孩子们想出的每一个新花样进行临场应对。就像这次的小汽车交易，两个男孩在任何谈判或合同中不可或缺的一部分上无法达成一致，那就是交易的起始日期。他们的交易是在周五学校吃腊肠披萨之前还是之后开始？
I'm getting pepperoni.
我要吃腊肠披萨。
So you want to start after--
所以你想在……之后开始。
I'm starting on Saturday.
我从周六开始。
But being a vegetarian starts on Friday.
但当素食者是从周五开始的。
No!
不！
Fine. It starts on Saturday.
好吧。从周六开始。
All right, good. Wait, can you guys shake on it? I think it's interesting.
好吧，很好。等等，你们能握手言和吗？我觉得这很有意思。
[THEO SCREAMING]
[西奥尖叫声]
Well, today on our program, people stuck in the middle. You know the saying "necessity is the mother of invention"? Being stuck in the middle of some situation is just like that because that is when ingenuity has to kick in. That is when you see people trying to MacGuyver their way out, trying stuff that it is surprising to see anyone try.
今天我们的节目主题是“身处中间的人”。你知道“需求是发明之母”那句话吗？身处困境就像那样，因为只有这时聪明才智才会发挥作用。那时你会看到人们试图用“马盖先”式的方法解决问题，尝试一些你意想不到的招数。
We have three stories today of three radically different sorts of situations and their outcomes. From WBEZ Chicago, it is This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天我们有三个关于三种完全不同处境及其结果的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, "Do You Hear What I Hear?" So there's certain locations that we all find ourselves in sometimes where we're just supposed to sit and wait, stuck in the middle of not exactly nowhere but nowhere interesting. I'm talking about the rows of chairs in airports that you sit in by the door for your flight, or doctor's office waiting rooms, and finally the mundane spot that one man found himself in over and over. Sara Corbett has this story about her father-in-law.
第一幕，“我听到了吗？”有些地方我们有时会发现自己身处其中，只是不得不坐在那里等待，被困在不完全是虚无、但也绝非有趣的地方。我说的是机场登机口前排成一排排的座椅，或者是医生的候诊室。最后是一个男人一遍又一遍发现自己身处的平凡地点。萨拉·科比特讲述她公公的故事。
I showed up for the first time at my father-in-law's house in 1992. He sat me down at the kitchen table, and we had a nice get-to-know-you sort of conversation. I was 24. Dick was about 60. And he pulled out a pen and took notes on what I was saying. At the time, I had no idea why he was doing this. But Dick is like this about everything that interests him.
我第一次去公公家是1992年。他让我坐在厨房桌前，我们进行了一次愉快的自我介绍式谈话。我当时24岁，迪克大约60岁。他拿出一支笔，把我说的内容记录下来。当时我不知道他为什么要这样做。但迪克对任何他感兴趣的事都这样。
He spent his entire career working for IBM, going back to the '50s and '60s, when working at IBM was like working at NASA. The kind of problems he worked on took weeks or months to solve, and he loved it. He's thorough, a process man. As Dick sees it, if something catches his attention, it's clearly worth gathering data on. And if it's worth gathering data on, it's worth getting to the bottom of-- including, recently, a certain piece of music.
他整个职业生涯都在IBM工作，可以追溯到50年代和60年代，那时在IBM工作就像在NASA工作一样。他解决的问题往往需要数周或数月的时间，他乐在其中。他非常彻底，是个程序导向的人。在迪克看来，如果某件事吸引了他的注意，那显然值得收集数据。如果值得收集数据，那就值得一探究竟——包括最近，一段特定的音乐。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hospital.
医院。
Hello. Could you do me a favor? This is a very unusual call, but you know the music you have, the holding music? When you put me on hold, it plays it. Could you do that for me for a minute?
你好。能帮个忙吗？这是一通很不寻常的电话，但你们保留的音乐，就是把我放在等候线时播放的那段音乐，能帮我播放一下吗？
OK.
好的。
I appreciate that very much.
非常感谢。
That's Dick. And for the last two years, he's been very, very interested in a piece of hold music.
那就是迪克。在过去两年里，他对一段保留音乐非常非常感兴趣。
The first time I heard it, when I was talking to Stamford Hospital, that's the call that started the whole thing. And I love the song. Just very unusual. It was bells and synthesizer, and I just-- clapping. It was an unusual piece. It's very hard to describe.
我第一次听到它时，是在我给斯坦福医院打电话时，那通电话开启了这一切。我喜欢那首歌。非常不寻常。那是钟声和合成器的声音，我只是……鼓掌。那是一段不寻常的作品。很难描述。
He heard the hold music again when he called a medical billing center in Atlanta and again with his cardiologist. And he had a hernia, then a kidney stone. This one song, it turns out, is the hold music for Dick's entire health care network. He's 81, in great health, but 81 is 81, and he's the one who deals with all the appointments, the follow-ups, the billing, both for him and his wife, Marianne.
当他致电亚特兰大一家医疗结算中心，以及联系他的心脏病专家时，他又听到了这段保留音乐。他得了疝气，然后是肾结石。事实证明，这一首歌是迪克整个医疗系统的保留音乐。他81岁，身体很健康，但81岁毕竟是81岁，他负责处理所有的预约、后续跟进和账单，不仅是他自己的，还有他妻子玛丽安的。
So if I called any number of doctors in the area, I would hear that music. And every time I heard it, it would just again remind me of what in the devil is that tune.
所以如果我给该地区的任何医生打电话，我都会听到那段音乐。每次听到它，都会再次提醒我，那到底是什么曲子？
He couldn't find the name of it. He couldn't find it, period, anywhere except on hold. And of course, he took notes on the phone calls where he was hearing it because Dick takes notes on every phone call. The song's not in the database of music apps like Shazam and SoundHound, by the way. Dick tried it. To identify the song, he needed human help, and a surprising number of people in medical offices, strangers he met over the phone, were willing to take this on. These were exactly the kind of people Dick is always looking for when he's on a quest.
他找不到歌名。无论如何都找不到，除了在保留通话中。当然，他在通话时做了记录，因为迪克在每个通话中都会做笔记。顺便说一句，这首歌不在Shazam和SoundHound等音乐应用的数据库中。迪克试过了。要识别这首歌，他需要人类的帮助，而医疗机构中令人惊讶的许多人，那些他在电话中遇到的陌生人，都愿意参与其中。这正是迪克在寻求帮助时一直寻找的那种人。
The kind of person that would get into it.
那种会投入其中的人。
A few people called their communications departments to see if they could turn anything up. No luck. A woman seven states away spent a whole weekend looking up songs online to try and find a match. Dead end.
有几个人打电话给他们的通信部门看能不能找出什么线索。没有结果。七个州外的一位女士花了一整个周末在网上搜索歌曲，试图找到匹配项。死胡同。
You know who was the least helpful? Dick's family. We did not get into it. Dick called us, his sons and daughters-in-law, and tried to hum the music over the phone. We blew it off. Dick described the hold song as haunting. But it was like a ghost none of us saw or even believed in, and he could tell.
你知道谁最不配合吗？迪克的家人。我们没参与进去。迪克打电话给我们，他的儿子和儿媳们，试着在电话里哼唱那段音乐。我们敷衍了事。迪克形容那段保留音乐是“萦绕心头的”。但它就像一个我们谁都看不见甚至不相信的幽灵，他能感觉得到。
I think when you get older, you get more of that in your life, where people are questioning whether you're really seeing it or you remember it right or whatever. And that does get you to feel a little isolated a little-- you know? Yes, you do. I did feel a little bit that way.
我想当你变老时，生活中会有更多这种情况，人们质疑你是否真的看到了它，或者你是否记得准确之类的。这确实让你感到有点孤立……你知道吗？是的，你真的会。我确实感到了那么一点。
And like, I can't go on keep asking people what's this music all about, and I can't describe it. And you sort of find that you better just let it go. And you don't want to, but it sort of fades after a while. Until you hear it again when you call another doctor's office, and then it's back. So I'll put those in here.
就像，我不能一直问别人这到底是什么音乐，我也无法描述它。你最终会觉得最好还是放手吧。你不想放手，但它一段时间后就会淡去。直到你给另一家医生办公室打电话再次听到它，它又回来了。所以我会把那些记在这里。
This is Dick going through some of the overstuffed cabinets at my house in Maine. He does this almost every time he comes to visit. He'll spend entire weekends in our basement, sorting out the tools we rarely use, collapsing all the empty cardboard boxes that accumulate down there. He'll sift through old papers, double check our tax returns. He sees in my cabinets a bonanza of things that need sorting and labeling.
这是迪克在翻阅我缅因州家里一些塞得满满的柜子。他每次来访几乎都会这样做。他会花整个周末在地下室，整理我们很少用的工具，折叠所有堆积在那里的空纸箱。他会翻阅旧文件，核对我们的报税表。他在我的柜子里看到了需要整理和标记的一大堆东西。
I think I'll get a box for all your goodies like this, one of those cardboard boxes, before we through them out. And I'll label it and put those together.
我想我会拿个箱子装你所有这些好东西，在丢掉之前装好。我会贴上标签，把它们放在一起。
This is the advantage of having a process man in the family. Dick stays with your problem until it's been solved, the cabinets or whatever. A couple of years ago, my husband and I were about to buy a new house when Dick swooped in and spent three days doing a copious market analysis, which made it clear that we were about to make a bad investment. He doesn't let himself off the hook for anything, big or small, because things don't let him off the hook.
这就是家庭里有一位“程序男”的好处。迪克会一直盯着你的问题直到解决，无论是柜子还是其他什么。几年前，我和丈夫正要买新房子时，迪克突然插手，花了三天时间做了大量的市场分析，明确指出我们差点做出错误的投资。他不会对自己做的事掉以轻心，无论大小，因为事情也不会对他掉以轻心。
Yeah, he's not fooling around.
没错，他一点都不含糊。
This is his wife, Marianne.
这是他的妻子，玛丽安。
With life or feelings or getting things right or doing it complete, there is nothing in his life that is inconsequential. Everything matters.
无论是生活、情感，还是把事情做好或做到完美，他生命中没有什么是无关紧要的。一切都很重要。
Can you think of anything that you've done that you did sloppily or hastily?
你能想到他做过什么草率或匆忙的事情吗？
Not really.
没有。
Nothing?
什么都没有？
I don't think so. It would be just not in my vocabulary to do something and say, OK, that's good enough. Let's go. And yet I don't say that's right. I really don't say that's right. And a lot of times I think that's wrong, and I should be on to something else.
我想没有。在他的词汇里没有做完一件事就说“好吧，这就够了，走吧”。然而我并不会说那是对的。我真的不会说那是对的。很多时候我认为那是错的，我应该继续做其他事。
I can hear the music in my head now.
我现在脑海里能听到那段音乐。
[HUMMING]
[哼唱]
This woman, Denise Carter Stanley, was Dick's jackpot. She's the registrar at the medical imaging center where he went one day to get a CAT scan.
这位女士，丹尼斯·卡特·斯坦利，是迪克的“头奖”。她是他有一天去做CT扫描时，医疗影像中心的登记员。
Great gal. She was a single mom, and she had been going to school at night. And we talked about a lot of things. And she was the kind of person that would get into it.
很棒的人。她是单亲妈妈，晚上一直在上学。我们聊了很多事情。她就是那种会投入其中的人。
Denise is on hold a lot inside the larger hospital network. She says she's been hearing the hold music every day for what she estimates is about an hour and a half a day for the last seven years. She likes the music. The first time Dick walked into her office, there was Denise playing the hold music, his hold music, on speakerphone at her desk.
丹尼斯在大型医院内部经常要处理等待接通的通话。她说过去七年里，她每天至少有一到一个半小时能听到那段保留音乐。她喜欢这段音乐。迪克第一次走进她办公室时，丹尼斯正把那段保留音乐——他的保留音乐——通过免提放在办公桌上播放。
In seven years, have other people asked you about the hold music?
这七年里，其他人问过你关于保留音乐的事吗？
Actually, they have. They have. But I just never got into it with them the way that he and I did. They were just, like, casually, yeah, that hold music, do you know who it's by? Like, no. But when he came in, it was really different. It was like he was really interested and really wanted to know.
其实，他们问过。他们问过。但我从来没像和他那样深入探讨过。他们只是随口问问，“嘿，那段保留音乐，你知道是谁创作的吗？”就像，不知道。但当他走进来时，情况真的很不同。就好像他真的非常有兴趣，真的想知道。
She called the IT department at her hospital. They thought she was crazy. She made more calls.
她给医院的IT部门打了电话。他们认为她疯了。她又打了更多电话。
Let me see if I still have all my information.
让我看看我是否还留着所有信息。
Are you like Dick that you keep notes on all this stuff?
你像迪克一样会记录所有这些资料吗？
Yeah, I do. Because sometimes you just get fixated on something, and you just have to know. And you can't rest until you know.
是的，我会。因为有时候你就是会对某件事产生执念，你必须知道真相。不弄明白你就无法安宁。
So you're a persistent person?
所以你是个坚持不懈的人？
Yes, very.
是的，非常。
When you recognize somebody else who's persistent, do you have a special bond with them?
当你认出另一个人也是坚持不懈时，你会和他们有特别的联系吗？
Yes, because I know then they get me. I get them, and they get me.
会，因为我知道他们懂我。我懂他们，他们也懂我。
So is that how you feel about Dick, that he's one of your tribe?
所以你觉得迪克是和你同类的人？
Yes.
是的。
Denise, digging around, finally turned up the key fact. The music came from Cisco, the company that provides the hospital's phone system. Cisco's the number one supplier of corporate phones like this in the world.
丹尼斯四处打探，最终找到了关键事实。音乐来自思科，这家公司为医院提供电话系统。思科是全球此类企业电话的头号供应商。
Dick went to his local library. And a woman there-- I want to say her name on the radio, because she cracked the case. Her name is Abby Sesselberg. She went to YouTube and found an audio recording that's called simply "One Hour of Cisco CallManager Default Hold Music."
迪克去了当地图书馆。那里的一位女士——我想在广播里说出她的名字，因为她破案了。她的名字叫艾比·塞塞尔伯格。她上网在YouTube上找到了一个简单的音频记录，标题是“思科CallManager默认保留音乐一小时”。
Can we do it? I want to hear it.
能播放吗？我想听听。
OK.
好的。
[MUSIC - TIM CARLETON AND DARRICK DEEL, "OPUS NO. 1"]
[音乐 - 蒂姆·卡尔顿和达里克·迪尔，《Opus No. 1》]
There are hundreds of comments posted about this song, pages and pages. And sure, some people can't stand it. But most of the comments are like this-- "Best hold music ever made. I love this song." "So addictively pleasant. Please, put me back on hold so I can listen to it some more." "I work in a call center, and this music is the best to listen to after dealing with rude customers." "I thought I was the only person who loved this." "I've been looking for this song for almost three years." Dick read these comments with relief.
关于这首歌有成百上千的评论，一页又一页。当然，有些人忍受不了。但大多数评论是这样的——“有史以来最好的保留音乐。我爱这首歌。”“太令人上瘾了。请把我重新放在等候线上，这样我就可以多听一会儿。”“我在呼叫中心工作，在处理粗鲁的客户后，听这段音乐最舒服。”“我以为只有我一个人喜欢它。”“我已经找这首歌找了快三年了。”迪克读着这些评论，感到如释重负。
I just can't seem to help myself. I have been calling and asking another department on campus to put me on hold. See? She's calling and asking people to put her on hold because I love that hold music. You see, there are other crazies, huh?
我就是忍不住。我一直打电话问校园里别的部门能不能把我放进等候线。看到没？她在打电话请人把她放在等候线上，因为我爱那段保留音乐。你看，还有别的“疯子”，对吧？
Well, I must say, from being, what, compulsive about it in the early times when I was trying to find them, saying, why are you so compulsive about this? You crazy? And then I started to read this, and I must say, it did a lot for my mental health.
嗯，我必须说，从早期的执迷不悟，试图找到它，对自己说“你为什么要这么执着？你疯了吗？”，然后我开始读这些评论，我必须说，这对我的心理健康很有帮助。
Yeah, you're feeling better about yourself now? You're not alone.
是啊，你现在感觉自己好多了？你并不孤单。
My mental condition, yeah.
我的心理状况，是的。
The librarian also helped Dick find a title for the song. It's called "Opus No. 1." And that's when I finally got into it. Dick, this is for you.
图书管理员还帮迪克找到了这首歌的名字。它叫《Opus No. 1》。就在那时，我终于参与进来了。迪克，这是送给你的。
My name is Tim Carlton, and I am the composer of "Opus No. 1."
我的名字是蒂姆·卡尔顿，我是《Opus No. 1》的作曲家。
You're hard to find, by the way. Do you know that about yourself?
顺便问一下，你很难找。你知道自己这一点吗？
Yeah. I don't really have much of a web presence.
是啊。我的网络影响力并不大。
Tim was 16 years old when he wrote "Opus No. 1." It was recorded in 1989 on a four track tape by one of his high school buddies, Darrick Deel. Tim was a Yanni-loving computer nerd, messing around with a drum machine and a synthesizer in his parents' garage in California.
蒂姆写《Opus No. 1》时才16岁。它是1989年在他父母加州的录音棚里，用四轨磁带和他高中的好友达里克·迪尔一起录制的。蒂姆当时是个热爱亚尼的电脑极客，在父母的车库里用鼓机和合成器乱搞。
That five minutes of tape is now on 65 million Cisco phone sets worldwide as the default hold music. It's what everyone hears unless someone inside the system makes an effort to change it. Tim was in his 20s when he got a call from Darrick about "Opus No. 1." Darrick had taken a job at Cisco designing phone systems.
那五分钟的磁带现在被全球6500万台思科电话系统作为默认保留音乐使用。除非系统内部有人努力更改它，否则每个人都会听到这个。蒂姆20多岁时接到了达里克的电话，谈到了《Opus No. 1》。达里克在思科谋得了一份设计电话系统的职务。
And he's like, dude, if you send this over and give us permission to do this, we can make this the default. I think I can get this in. And it was like putting an Easter egg in a DVD or software-- just like a little hidden gem that, oh yeah, the next time you're on hold, it might be my music. I just thought it would be a cool piece of trivia.
他说，伙计，如果你把这个发过来并授权给我们，我们可以把它设为默认。我觉得我能把它加进去。这就像在DVD或软件中放入一个“彩蛋”——只是一个小小的隐藏宝藏，噢，是的，下次你被放在等候线上时，那可能就是我的音乐。我当时只觉得这会是个很酷的小趣事。
So and then technically, what happened? So they license the music from you? I mean, do they renew their license every few years? Like, are you making any money off of it?
那从技术上讲，发生了什么？他们从你那里购买了音乐版权吗？我的意思是，他们每几年会续约吗？你靠它赚到钱了吗？
Not a penny. So I think that's probably my most legit claim as a music artist. I didn't make any money for my music.
一分钱没赚。所以我认为这可能是我作为音乐艺术家最“合法”的说法。我没靠音乐赚到钱。
Tim's not a musician anymore. He's an IT guy now. He manages the server at a bank in California.
蒂姆不再是音乐人了。他现在是IT工作者。他在加州一家银行管理服务器。
What is it like to be put on hold and hear your own music?
被放在等候线上并听到自己的音乐是什么感觉？
It's really embarrassing when you're not expecting to hear that, and then all of a sudden you have that memory pop up. I just start blushing immediately. It's just-- it's a different time. It's not the same person I am today.
当你没预料到会听到它，突然间那个记忆冒出来时，真的很尴尬。我立刻就开始脸红。这只是……那是不同的时代。不是今天的我。
So is it sort of like looking back at a picture of yourself from 1987 and saying, oh, why was I wearing that outfit?
所以这就像回头看一张1987年的照片，心想，“噢，我当时为什么要穿那套衣服”？
Oh, exactly. That's exactly it.
噢，完全正确。就是这样。
So has it ever yielded anything good for you? I mean, if it hasn't made you money, has anybody ever bought you a drink at a bar? Have you picked up women with it?
那它给你带来过什么好处吗？我的意思是，如果它没让你赚钱，有没有人在酒吧请你喝过酒？你用它搭讪过女人吗？
No.
没有。
You know, is there any rock star application here?
你知道，这里面有什么摇滚明星的潜质吗？
No, I don't think I've ever actually tried to use the, you know, I wrote the default  hold music for a lot of companies.
没有，我不觉得我真的尝试用过那个，你知道，“我是很多公司的默认保留音乐作曲家”这种梗。
Tim and Darrick are still friends. And Darrick's the only one, after all these years, making any sort of music. He creates new ringtones for phones, which Tim admits he's a little jealous of.
蒂姆和达里克依然是朋友。达里克是多年后唯一还在做音乐的人。他为手机创作新的铃声，蒂姆承认对此有点嫉妒。
It's something that people are choosing to put on their phone as opposed to this music being forced on them. I think that would have been more entertaining to me.
这是人们选择放入手机里的东西，而不是被强迫听的。我觉得那对我来说会更有趣。
I see. So yeah, you feel like your music has been forced on millions of people?
我明白了。所以，你觉得你的音乐是被强迫推给了数百万人？
Yes.
是的。
So it's not exactly something to brag about?
所以这并不是什么可以炫耀的事？
That's, I think, the source of my embarrassment, yeah.
我想这就是我尴尬的根源，是的。
I told Tim my father-in-law wanted a copy of the song to put on his iPod, because he wants to play it around the house as he does chores and pays bills. In the comments on YouTube, lots of people said they wanted a copy. Tim found this almost impossible to fathom, but he and Darrick sent it anyway, full fidelity, in stereo.
我告诉蒂姆我公公想要一份这首歌拷贝放在他的iPod里，因为他想在做家务和缴费时播放。在YouTube的评论里，很多人都说他们想要一份。蒂姆觉得这几乎不可思议，但他和达里克还是发了，高保真，立体声。
[MUSIC - TIM CARLETON AND DARRICK DEEL, "OPUS NO. 1"]
[音乐 - 蒂姆·卡尔顿和达里克·迪尔，《Opus No. 1》]
Sara Corbett is the co-author most recently of A House in the Sky . If you have not had enough of this song, "Opus 1" is available at better hospital phone systems and for a limited time at our website, thisamericanlife.org, in full fidelity stereo for your downloading needs.
萨拉·科比特是《天空中的房子》的合著者。如果你还没听够这首歌，《Opus No. 1》可以在更好的医院电话系统中找到，并且在有限的时间内，可以在我们的网站thisamericanlife.org上下载全保真立体声版本。
[MUSIC - THE FOUR FRESHMAN, "NOWHERE TO GO"]
[音乐 - 四个新生代合唱团，《无处可去》]
Coming up, the karate yid. That's an anti-Semitic, right, to say yid? Well, and if it is anti-Semitic, is if one of those anti-Semitic things that I'm allowed to say because I am a Jew? Is even asking that question anti-Semitic? Anyway, Orthodox Jews skilled in karate. You'll see what I'm talking about in a minute-- from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
即将播出，空手道犹太人。说“yid”（犹太佬）是反犹吗？嗯，如果它是反犹的，那作为一名犹太人，我可以说这种反犹的话吗？甚至问这个问题本身反犹吗？总之，精通空手道的东正教犹太人。片刻之后，你会明白我在说什么——来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program "Stuck in the Middle," stories of people who cannot get out of some situation, some limbo they are caught in. And so they use ingenuity and guile, or anyway unconventional means to get themselves unstuck. We have arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, "Sunrise, Sun-Get."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，带给您关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目是“身处中间”，讲述那些无法摆脱某种处境、被困在某种“林波”中的人们的故事。因此，他们运用聪明才智和诡计，或者至少是非传统的手段让自己脱困。我们现在进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，“日出，得克”。
Not that long ago, there was a kind of wacky news story that was news for a day or so in New York City. It was on the cover of the tabloids. It was on all the local news channels in the tri-state area. And at its heart were people stuck in a kind of limbo. Mark Oppenheimer has more.
不久前，纽约市出现了一个轰动新闻，那也是一天左右的新闻头条。它登上了小报封面。它在三州地区的所有当地新闻频道上播出。核心是一群被困在某种“林波”中的人。马克·奥本海默有更多报道。
The news was pretty startling. A group of men, including a Brooklyn rabbi named Mendel Epstein, had been arrested for conspiring to kidnap a husband and torture him until he gave his wife a get. The get is simply a piece of paper a husband hands his wife saying, essentially, it's over. We're divorced. Jews can get civil divorces like anyone else, but if you're an Orthodox Jew, strictly following Jewish law, the get is the only real way to end a marriage.
新闻相当惊人。一群男人，包括布鲁克林的拉比门德尔·爱泼斯坦，因密谋绑架一名丈夫并对其进行折磨，直到他给妻子“得克”而被捕。“得克”就是丈夫交给妻子的一张纸，本质上说：结束了。我们离婚了。犹太人可以像任何人一样进行民事离婚，但如果你是东正教犹太人，严格遵守犹太律法，“得克”是结束婚姻的唯一真正方式。
Usually this goes off without a hitch. But sometimes a woman wants to get divorced and the husband refuses to give a get. That's where Rabbi Epstein came in.
通常这一切顺利。但有时妻子想离婚，丈夫却拒绝给“得克”。这就是拉比爱泼斯坦介入的地方。
According to the complaint, Epstein talked about forcing compliance through the use of tough guys who utilize electric cattle prods, karate, handcuffs, and place plastic bags over the heads of the husbands.
根据起诉书，爱泼斯坦谈到通过使用暴徒来强迫服从，这些人利用电击棒、空手道、手铐，并把塑料袋套在丈夫的头上。
The criminal complaint against Epstein and a fellow rabbi, Martin Wolmark, alleged that the rabbis agreed to arrange a beat down of  a reluctant husband, and they were asking for more than $50,000 to do it. Here's the US attorney for New Jersey, Paul Fishman, laying this all out to the press.
针对爱泼斯坦和另一位拉比马丁·沃尔马克刑事起诉书称，拉比们同意安排殴打不情愿的丈夫，他们为此索要超过5万美元。这是美国新泽西州联邦检察官保罗·费什曼向媒体公布的所有细节。
The charge are kidnapping and extortion, violent crime, to get Jewish men to give divorces that they wouldn't otherwise give. And it's not really an exercise of religion. It's really about money and violent crime.
指控是绑架、勒索和暴力犯罪，迫使犹太男性给予本不会给予的离婚。这不是真正的宗教实践。这实际上是关于金钱和暴力犯罪。
When the story first broke, what kind of got lost is that it's not just about cash, karate, and cattle prods. It's also about women who were stuck, essentially trapped in failed marriages. For the past couple of years as a religion reporter, I've been interviewing Jewish women in just this situation, and it can be pretty horrible. Some men refuse to give a get because they still love their wives and hope to reconcile. But others just want leverage so they can demand, for example, lots of money.
当这事第一次爆发时，人们忽略的是这不仅仅是关于现金、空手道和电击棒。它也关于那些被困住的女性，本质上是被困在失败的婚姻中。过去几年里作为宗教记者，我一直在采访处于这种境地的犹太女性，那真的很可怕。有些男人拒绝给“得克”是因为他们还爱着妻子并希望复合。但另一些人只是想要筹码，比如索要巨额金钱。
Anywhere between half a million and $2 million, depending on the day and, I guess, the position of the sun in the sky.
根据当天的不同，大概在50万到200万美元之间，我猜，这取决于天空太阳的位置。
This is Gital Dodelson. She's an Orthodox Jewish woman, and she's what's known as an agunah. That's the word in Hebrew for a woman whose husband refuses to give her a divorce. Literally, it means a chained wife. Besides money, lots of money, Gital says her husband has a long list of demands for her to meet if she wants her get.
这是吉塔尔·多德尔森。她是东正教犹太女性，被称为“阿古纳”（agunah）。这是希伯来语，指丈夫拒绝给她离婚的女性。字面意思是“被锁链拴住的妻子”。除了钱，巨额金钱，吉塔尔说如果她想要“得克”，她的丈夫还有一长串要求要她满足。
I have a four-year-old son. He wants 50-50 custody, where my son would be a week with me and a week with him.
我有一个四岁的儿子。他想要50-50监护权，我儿子一周跟我住，一周跟他住。
But Gital lives in New Jersey. Her husband's on Staten Island. The boy would have to enroll in two schools and alternate weeks. Keep in mind, Gital already has a civil divorce, and the custody and financial arrangements have been settled by a judge.
但吉塔尔住在新泽西。她丈夫在斯塔滕岛。孩子不得不进入两所学校并每周轮换。请记住，吉塔尔已经民事离婚了，监护权和财务安排已经由法官裁定。
Gital says that her husband-- who, by the way, didn't return my calls-- is always changing what he's asking for. At one point, she says, he demanded they get rid of the coordinator who's overseeing the custody of their son. Another time, he insisted that she promise to tell the boy someday that the divorce was all his mother's fault. Gital says she should have seen it coming.
吉塔尔说她的丈夫——顺便说一句，他没有回我的电话——总是改变他的要求。有一次，她说，他要求解雇监督孩子监护权的协调员。另一次，他坚持让她承诺有一天告诉孩子离婚全是母亲的错。吉塔尔说她早该料到的。
I was young and dumb, and there were a lot of things that maybe should have been red flags that I wasn't paying attention to. While we were dating, he told me once that he's always right. Now, I laughed, because I don't know, who says that? No one says that seriously. So I assumed he was joking. And he wasn't joking.
我当时又年轻又笨，有很多事情也许本应是危险信号但我没注意。我们约会时，他曾说他总是对的。当时我笑了，因为我不知道，谁会那样说？没人会当真。所以我以为他在开玩笑。但他不是开玩笑。
You know, a week into my marriage I was looking back and kicking myself because, I mean, I should have stopped dating him right there. But I didn't realize. And by the time I realized, it was too late.
你知道，结婚一周后，我回首往事并自责，因为我的意思是，我本该在那时就停止约会。但我没意识到。等我意识到时，已经太迟了。
I actually find it easier to explain now that he hasn't given a get for four years, because the way he's trying to control me now, through the get, that's what he tried to do throughout the whole marriage. Everything was subject to his control and subject to his demands. He had to have a final say in everything, even in what we were having for supper or the brand of laundry detergent that I used or anything. And nothing was too small for him to care about.
我现在其实觉得解释这一点更容易，因为他四年没给“得克”了，因为他现在试图控制我的方式，通过“得克”，那就是他在整个婚姻中试图做的事情。一切都要受到他的控制和要求。他必须在所有事情上拥有最终决定权，甚至是我们晚餐吃什么，或者是用的洗衣粉品牌，任何事情。对他来说没有太小的事。
Of course, there are always two sides to every divorce. And I tried to get her husband's side. When he didn't call back, I tried his parents, his uncle, even his grandmother-- his bubbe-- and none of them would talk to me.
当然，每段离婚都有两面。我试图得到她丈夫那边的说法。当他没回电话时，我试着联系他的父母、叔叔，甚至他的祖母——他的奶奶——没一个人愿意跟我谈。
I finally spoke with her husband's lawyer, who disputed nearly every one of Gital's assertions. He said the sticking points for his client are tiny, reasonable things, like what hour on Friday he can pick up his son so he doesn't have to drive after Sabbath begins at sundown.
我最终和她丈夫的律师谈了，他反驳了吉塔尔的几乎所有断言。他说他客户的症结是细小的、合理的事情，比如周五几点钟他可以接儿子，这样他就不必在安息日太阳落山开始后开车。
But Gital's side of the story has been backed up by a rabbinic court called a beis din. A beis din is a group of three rabbis Orthodox Jew sometimes turn to to settle disputes outside the civil courts. When her husband wouldn't give a get, Gital tried to bring him before the beis din. But he refused to show up.
但吉塔尔的说法得到了一个叫“贝斯·丁”（beis din）的拉比法庭的支持。贝斯·丁是由三位拉比组成的团体，东正教犹太人有时会通过它在民事法院之外解决纠纷。当她丈夫不给“得克”时，吉塔尔试图把他带到贝斯·丁。但他拒绝露面。
So the rabbis issued something called a seruv. It's basically a contempt of court. It's supposed to ostracize him in the community. Gital's brother Aryeh is a full-time scholar of Jewish law, and he says the seruv is usually an effective tool.
所以拉比们发布了一个叫“塞鲁夫”（seruv）的文件。基本上就是藐视法庭的裁定。它旨在让他在社区中被排斥。吉塔尔的兄弟阿里耶是一名全职犹太律法学者，他说“塞鲁夫”通常是一个有效的工具。
No, a seruv, if followed properly by the community, is an incredibly powerful thing. It sort of cuts him off from every aspect of Jewish life. I mean, you can't stand within six square feet, eight square feet, whatever it is, of him. You can't count him for a minyan.
不，如果社区执行得当，“塞鲁夫”是非常强大的工具。它基本上把他从犹太生活的各个方面切断了。我的意思是，你不能站在他六平方英尺、八平方英尺，无论多大范围之内。你不能把他算进“米扬”（minyan）里。
The minyan is the quorum of 10 men needed for an Orthodox prayer service. It's sort of like telling a devout Catholic that he can't receive communion.
米扬是东正教祈祷仪式所需的10名男性的法定人数。这就像告诉一个虔诚的天主教徒他不能领圣餐一样。
You can't give him an aliyah. He can't be called up to the torah in shul, which, as you know, it's a big honor, and he doesn't get that anymore. He can't serve as a hazzan there in the shul.
你不能给他“阿利亚”（aliyah）。在犹太会堂里，他不能被叫上去念托拉，如你所知，那是一个很大的荣誉，他再也没这个机会了。他不能在犹太会堂里担任领诵。
Chanting prayer. He can't do that. You're supposed to boycott his business, I think? Well, you can't be near him, right?
吟唱祈祷词。他做不到。我想，你还应该抵制他的生意？嗯，你不能靠近他，对吧？
Right. You can't be near him. So theoretically, if followed properly, it should be enough to both shame them, as well as on a practical level, they're losing all their contacts. You're not supposed to talk to him. You can't give him a ride, can't do him a favor.
对。你不能靠近他。所以理论上，如果执行得当，这应该足以让他们感到羞耻，而且在实际层面上，他们失去了所有的联系。你不应该跟他说话。你不能让他搭车，不能帮他忙。
This sort of ostracism would have worked back in the old country, where you spent your whole life around the same couple thousand people. If you were the village cobbler and all of a sudden you had no customers, you probably figured that it made sense to give your wife a get. But in the modern world, a seruv doesn't always work so well. Aryeh believes that the Orthodox Jews on Staten Island, where his brother-in-law lives, are still treating him like one of their own, so the shaming and community pressure isn't working.
这种排斥在老家可能有效，因为你一生都生活在相同的几千人周围。如果你是村里的鞋匠，突然之间没生意了，你可能就会觉得给妻子“得克”是有道理的。但在现代世界，“塞鲁夫”并不总是那么奏效。阿里耶认为，他妹夫居住的斯塔滕岛上的东正教犹太人依然把他当作自己人，所以羞辱和社区压力没起作用。
Gital, of course, could just walk away. She's already got her civil divorce. The finances are all settled. So is the child custody. But she can't get remarried. She's a 25-year-old woman. She'd like to have more kids.
吉塔尔当然可以走开。她已经民事离婚了。财务已全部解决。孩子监护权也一样。但她不能再婚。她才25岁。她还想生更多的孩子。
And I should point out, most Jews wouldn't care. Plenty of less religious Jews would be happy to marry Gital. But in the Orthodox world, where she was raised, where her whole family is, where she wants to stay, she can't make a new life for herself. Her ex-husband can cast about for a new wife and then give Gital a get if he finds somebody. But for Gital, it's different.
而且我应该指出，大多数犹太人不会在意。许多不太虔诚的犹太人会很乐意娶吉塔尔。但在东正教世界，她是在那里长大的，她全家都在那里，她想留在那里，她无法为自己开始新生活。她的前夫可以寻觅新妻子，如果他找到了人，就给吉塔尔一个“得克”。但对吉塔尔来说，情况不同。
What would it be like? I mean, could you date?
那会是什么感觉？我的意思是，你能约会吗？
Well, I mean, in my community you don't date unless you're actively looking to get married. And since I'm already married, that would pose a little bit of a problem. I don't think I could find anyone who would be willing to date me under these circumstances, where I say, hey, I'm looking to get married, but you might have to wait two or three or four, 10 or 20 years, because there's this man who's refusing to give me the get.
嗯，在我的社区，除非你积极地寻找结婚对象，否则你不会约会。既然我已经结婚了，这会构成一点问题。我不认为我能找到在这种情况下愿意和我约会的人，我会说，“嘿，我正在寻找结婚对象，但你可能得等两、三、四年，甚至10年、20年，因为这个男人拒绝给我得克。”
And he doesn't feel any urgency because he can get out of it whenever he wants. He can give me a get and be done with the whole thing within a day, as soon as he decides he wants to. So for him, it's just a waiting game where why not wait longer.
而且他没有任何紧迫感，因为他随时都可以摆脱它。他随时可以给我“得克”，在一天之内完成所有事情，只要他决定他想这么做。所以对他来说，这只是个等待游戏，为什么不等等看呢。
If his demands were something that I could give, I would have given in a long time ago because this life is agony. I mean, to wait and wait and never know and to be tied together like this, I would give anything I could to be finished with it.
如果他的要求是我能给予的，我早就妥协了，因为这种生活简直是折磨。我的意思是，等待再等待，永远不知道未来，被这样绑在一起，我愿意付出一切代价来结束它。
Almost anything. She wouldn't resort to violence or hire a rabbi like Mendel Epstein, the rabbi who was arrested in Brooklyn. Now, most of Epstein's work was above board. He'd advocate for women in rabbinic court. He'd serve as a go-between with the husband's family. That's how he made his living. But according to the FBI, Epstein took his work on behalf of women one step too far.
几乎一切。她不会诉诸暴力或雇用像门德尔·爱泼斯坦那样的拉比，就是那个在布鲁克林被捕的拉比。大多数爱泼斯坦的工作是合法的。他会为女性在拉比法庭上辩护。他会充当丈夫家庭之间的中间人。这就是他谋生的方式。但根据FBI的说法，爱泼斯坦为女性代理的工作做得太过了。
Rabbi Epstein, I should mention, is currently out on bail, but neither he nor his lawyer responded to my request for an interview. However, about a year ago, before he was arrested, I actually met him, interviewed him at his dining room table. I recorded it on my phone. The interview started off pretty uneventful.
我应该提到，拉比爱泼斯坦目前在保释中，但他和他的律师都没有回应我的采访请求。然而，大约一年前，在他被捕前，我确实见过他，在他的餐桌旁采访了他。我用手机录了下来。采访开始时相当平静。
So tell me what you do. Explain to me what you do.
那么告诉我你是做什么的。向我解释一下你的工作。
Well, on the simplest level, people come to ask if they should get divorced.
嗯，在最简单的层面上，人们来问是否应该离婚。
At some point the interview kind of took a turn. Epstein told me about this case from 1992, when he got a call from a chained wife named Jennifer Klein. She had a civil divorce but no get, and now her ex-husband had kidnapped their young son and fled to Peru.
在采访的某个时刻，情况有点转折。爱泼斯坦告诉了我一个1992年的案件，当时他接到一位名叫詹妮弗·克莱恩的被锁链拴住的妻子的电话。她民事离婚了但没有“得克”，现在她的前夫绑架了他们年幼的儿子并逃到了秘鲁。
Epstein says he told her, call the FBI. She said she'd done that. But she'd also heard that Rabbi Epstein could do things that the FBI couldn't do. Epstein told me that the woman had already found a group of ex-CIA agents who were going to help her find her husband and child.
爱泼斯坦说他告诉她，打电话给FBI。她说她已经做了。但她也听说拉比爱泼斯坦能做FBI做不到的事。爱泼斯坦告诉我，那个女人已经找了一群前CIA特工，他们会帮助她找到丈夫和孩子。
How'd she find them?
她是怎么找到他们的？
I don't know.
我不知道。
You didn't find them?
不是你找到他们的？
She found them Nothing to do with us. She found them.
她找到他们的，跟我们没关系。是她找到的。
Epstein says she found them. Nothing to do with us. Epstein's daughter Batsheva, a lawyer, was sitting right next to him, so he was choosing his words carefully, but not super carefully.
爱泼斯坦说是她找到的。跟我们没关系。爱泼斯坦的女儿巴特谢娃是个律师，就坐在他旁边，所以他选词很小心，但也不是特别小心。
As he continued with his story, he, the wife, the former secret agent man, and a Jewish scribe are all bound for Peru. They find the husband, break into the house. The kid's there. They save him. And then they head to the bathroom, where the hired muscle had found the husband.
当他继续讲他的故事时，他和那个妻子、前特工、一名犹太抄写员都准备去秘鲁。他们找到了丈夫，闯进屋子。孩子在那里。他们救了他。然后他们去了浴室，雇来的打手在那里找到了丈夫。
The husband was already down on the floor, completely naked. Seems he was taking a shower with the Indian maid. We put him down.
丈夫当时已经倒在地板上，完全裸体。看来他正在和印度女佣洗澡。我们把他制服了。
There were pictures of that.
有那张照片。
And then we had a conversation with him. He said the words he had to say. Please write-- he didn't say please. Write and give a get to my wife. And I agreed to it. You're the messengers. He did everything he had to do. So they also made--
然后我们和他进行了对话。他说出了他必须说的话。请写……他不说是“请”。写并把“得克”给我的妻子。我同意了。你们是信使。他做了他必须做的一切。所以他们也让……
So how did the CIA man convince him to give the get?
那么CIA特工是怎么说服他给“得克”的？
I don't know if we want to discuss that.
我不知道我们是否想讨论这个。
I don't know if we want to discuss that, his daughter said.
“我不知道我们是否想讨论这个，”他女儿说。
Let's just say it got a little physical.
我们只能说，过程有点“身体接触”。
Gotcha.
懂了。
Now the CIA has this little pill.
现在CIA有这种小药片。
Just to be clear, the guy was an ex-Delta Forces commando, not CIA. But whatever.
说明一下，那个人是前三角洲部队突击队员，不是CIA。但不管怎样。
The CIA has this little pill. They put it in his mouth. In a second, out cold. So the guy weighed about 200 pounds. We lifted the guy up, and we put him in the bathtub, locked the door.
CIA有这种小药片。他们把它放进他嘴里。一秒钟，就晕过去了。那家伙重约200磅。我们把他抬起来，放进浴缸，锁上门。
I asked the guy in the CIA, how long is he going to sleep? When will he wake up? So he said, Rabbi, we don't do diagnostics here. You know, no one did a blood test, like you do in a hospital. First of all, if he wakes up. I said, what do you-- whoa! Not if it is-- if he wakes up.
我问那个CIA的人，他要睡多久？什么时候会醒？他说，拉比，我们这不做诊断。你知道，没人做验血，像医院那样。首先，如果他醒的话。我说，你说什么……哇！不是“如果”，是“当他醒的时候”。
The Houston Chronicle reported on this story in 1992 and ran a photo of the woman and her son, reunited and posing with the hired gun from the Delta Forces. There are legends that this is exactly how these matters got settled back in the Eastern European villages. You hired a thug from the czar's army, he gave the husband a little talking to, and suddenly you had your get. Similar legends had floated around Epstein.
《休斯顿纪事报》1992年报道了这个故事，刊登了那个女人和她儿子的照片，他们重聚了，并与那个三角洲部队的雇佣枪手合影。有传说称这正是东欧乡村解决这些问题的方式。你雇了一个沙皇军队的恶棍，他跟丈夫谈了谈，突然你就有了“得克”。类似的传说也在爱泼斯坦身边流传。
The violence that he's accused of doing now I would never have dreamed that that was what he engaged in.
他现在被指控做的暴力行为，我做梦也没想到他会参与其中。
This is Rivka Haut. 30 years ago, Rivka and a couple friends founded an organization to help free agunot. And back then, they worked with Mendel Epstein. She says, like everyone, she heard the rumors about some of his tactics. But she never imagined anything like what he's accused of now.
这是里夫卡·豪特。30年前，里夫卡和几个朋友成立了一个组织来帮助释放“阿古纳”。当时，她们和门德尔·爱泼斯坦共事。她说，像大家一样，她也听到了关于他某些手段的传闻。但她从没想象过他现在被指控的那种程度。
I was very saddened because I knew Mendel many years. And I still feel very sad about it. I figured the most he does is grab men and kind of threaten them. He's a big man. You've seen him. You know that he's physically a big man. And I-- like a little fistfight or slapping around. That was my assumption.
我感到非常难过，因为我认识门德尔很多年了。我现在依然感到非常悲伤。我以为他做的最多也就是抓住男人，威胁他们一下。他是个大块头。你见过他。你知道他在身体上是个大个子。我……就像小小的斗殴或打耳光之类的。这是我的假设。
Over the last few decades, as more Orthodox women decided it was OK to get divorced, Mendel Epstein got a reputation as the rabbi women could trust. He was willing to take the women's side. He even published a little handbook to guide women through the divorce process.
在过去几十年里，随着越来越多的东正教女性认为离婚是可以接受的，门德尔·爱泼斯坦作为“女性可以信任的拉比”而闻名。他愿意站在女性一边。他甚至出版了一本小手册来指导女性进行离婚程序。
And Rivka says, Epstein was her guide too. She and her fellow activists were all Orthodox, but they were pretty modern. They had TVs in their houses, some of them wore pants, so they needed someone like Epstein to help them establish trust with the ultra-Orthodox women who needed their help.
里夫卡说，爱泼斯坦也是她的向导。她和她的同伴活动家都是东正教徒，但她们相当现代。她们家里有电视，有些人穿裤子，所以她们需要像爱泼斯坦这样的人帮助她们与需要她们帮助的极端东正教女性建立信任。
Mendel Epstein that I knew way back when was a mentor to us. He told us a lot about agunot, and he was a great help to agunot. He tried to do the right thing, and he was out to get justice for women. And he did. He helped many, many women.
我当年认识的那个门德尔·爱泼斯坦是我们的导师。他告诉了我们很多关于“阿古纳”的事情，他是“阿古纳”的巨大帮助。他试图做正确的事，他致力于为女性伸张正义。他做到了。他帮助了许多许多女性。
Then at some point, she can't remember if it was 10 years or 20 years ago, there was an incident, and her opinion of Epstein changed.
后来在某个时刻，她记不清是10年前还是20年前了，发生了一件事，她对爱泼斯坦的看法变了。
The way it worked for me, we were working on a particular case. And he called me the night before, and he was bad-mouth-- he started saying very bad things about this woman, who was a wonderful woman.
对我来说，当时我们正在处理一个特别的案例。头天晚上他打电话给我，他开始说那个女人的坏话——那是位了不起的女人。
And I was shocked. And I said, what are you talking about? We're going out tomorrow. We're demonstrating on her behalf.
我很震惊。我说，你在说什么？我们明天要出去。我们要为她示威。
He said, no, you're not, because you don't have a seruv. And I said, we have a seruv. I'm holding it in my hand. It's a rabbinic court document. He said, no, I got them to rescind it. I had them rescind it, and you can't go out. You don't have a seruv.
他说，不，你们不能，因为你们没有“塞鲁夫”。我说，我们有“塞鲁夫”。我正拿在手里。那是拉比法庭的文件。他说，不，我让他们撤销了。我让他们撤销了，你们不能出去。你们没有“塞鲁夫”。
Why had he had it rescinded?
为什么他要让人撤销它？
Because he went to work for her husband.
因为他去给她的丈夫工作了。
Oh.
噢。
If an attorney would do that, they'd get disbarred. But these rules don't apply. So he stopped working for her.
如果律师这样做，他们会被吊销执照。但这些规则不适用。所以他停止为她工作了。
The Husband made him a better offer?
那个丈夫给了他更好的条件？
I guess. I guess. And that was a different face of him. And at that point, we had to tell women, don't ask him for help, and don't go to him.
我想是吧。我想是吧。那是他的另一张脸。从那时起，我们不得不告诉女性，别寻求他的帮助，别去找他。
A colleague of Rivka's remembered this too. Again, Epstein and his attorney declined to talk to me about any of this. Right now, a lot of Orthodox Jews are pretty embarrassed by these husbands who won't free their wives. It's cruel, and they know it looks very bad to the outside world. A couple of solutions have been floated. One would be to grant women annulments, like in the Catholic Church. One well-known aguna in the Orthodox world, Tamar Epstein, recently announced that she considers herself free of her marriage, and everyone assumes it's because she found a rabbi to annul it.
里夫卡的一位同事也记得这件事。同样，爱泼斯坦和他的律师拒绝跟我谈论这些。现在，很多东正教犹太人对这些不愿放过妻子的丈夫感到非常尴尬。这很残忍，他们知道这对外界来说很难看。已经提出了几个解决方案。一个是像天主教会那样给予女性婚姻无效宣告。东正教世界一位著名的“阿古纳”塔玛尔·爱泼斯坦最近宣布，她认为自己已经从婚姻中解脱了，每个人都认为那是因为她找到了拉比宣告婚姻无效。
But this idea is controversial. It hasn't caught on, not yet. So for now, if you're an aguna like Gital Dodelson, a desperate woman trapped in this limbo, paying some rabbi to intervene almost makes sense.
但这个想法很有争议。还没流行起来，至少现在还没有。所以现在，如果你像吉塔尔·多德尔森那样是一个“阿古纳”，一个陷入这种“林波”的绝望女性，付钱给某个拉比介入几乎是有道理的。
You know what? The numbers that I've heard, my husband is demanding a lot more than that for the get. So you're telling me I would pay a third party a small amount of money and he'll get rid of the problem for me instead of having to fight it out with my husband and give him much, much, much more? If you take out the fact that he's beating people up, that sounds like a pretty good deal.
你知道吗？我听到的数字，我丈夫要求的比那多得多。所以你的意思是我会付给第三方一小笔钱，他就会为我解决问题，而不是必须和我的丈夫抗争并给他更多更多更多的钱？如果你去掉他殴打人的事实，这听起来是一笔相当不错的交易。
Not that she'd ever hire someone to beat up her ex. She's not willing to go that far. But as it happens, there's an old Jewish teaching that recalcitrant husbands should be beaten. And it wasn't some schmuck from Brooklyn who said so. It was Maimonides, the 12th century Spanish rabbi considered the greatest Jewish sage of all time.
并不是说她会雇人去殴打前夫。她不愿意走那么远。但恰巧，有一条古老的犹太教义说顽固的丈夫应该被殴打。说这话的不是布鲁克林的什么混混。而是迈蒙尼德，12世纪西班牙拉比，被认为是有史以来最伟大的犹太圣人。
Maimonides wrote that a man could be beaten until he gave his wife a get. Here was his reasoning. Deep down, he said, all of us are torn between our good inclinations and our evil inclinations. And being beaten might be just what a man needs to drive out his evil side so that he can see the wisdom of releasing his wife. Maimonides doesn't say anything about karate chops and cattle prods, but the principle's the same.
迈蒙尼德写道，男人可以被殴打，直到他给妻子“得克”。他的理由是：在内心深处，他说，我们所有人都被善的倾向和恶的倾向所撕裂。而被殴打可能正是男人驱除邪恶一面所需要的，这样他才能看到释放妻子的智慧。迈蒙尼德没说空手道或电击棒，但原则是一样的。
Mark Oppenheimer. He writes the Beliefs column for the New York Times , and he's writing a book about chained wives. Since we first broadcast this story a year ago, Gital did finally get her get. And Mendel Epstein is currently on trial in New Jersey for allegedly asking undercover agents for $60,000 to kidnap a man and force him to grant his wife a divorce.
马克·奥本海默。他在《纽约时报》撰写“信仰”专栏，正在写一本关于被锁链拴住的妻子的书。自从我们一年前第一次播出这个故事以来，吉塔尔最终确实拿到了她的“得克”。而门德尔·爱泼斯坦目前正在新泽西州受审，罪名是涉嫌索要6万美元诱骗卧底特工绑架一名男子并强迫其给予妻子离婚。
[MUSIC - WAXAHATCHEE, "BLUE, PT. II"]
[音乐 - 瓦克斯哈奇，《蓝色，第二部分》]
Act Three, "Contrails of my Tears." Well, when you're on an airplane, you are definitely stuck in the middle between the place that you left and the place that you are going. And Brett Martin says in that atmospheric limbo, things are different for us in at least one significant way.
第三幕，“我泪水的凝结尾”。嗯，当你坐飞机时，你绝对被困在离开的地方和要去的地方之间的中间地带。布雷特·马丁说，在那种大气的“林波”中，至少有一个重要的方面让我们变得不同。
A couple of years ago, I was on a flight from New York to San Juan, Puerto Rico. The movie was Sweet Home Alabama , which you'll remember is about a Southern girl played by Reese Witherspoon who moves to New York, joins the fashion industry, and then is forced to return home and come to terms with her white trash roots. At the end, there's a wedding scene when the character has to explain to her big city husband-to-be that she's leaving him for her earthy, down home high school sweetheart.
几年前，我坐飞机从纽约飞往波多黎各圣胡安。播放的电影是《情归阿拉巴马》，你可能还记得，那部电影讲述了一个由瑞茜·威瑟斯彭饰演的南方女孩移居纽约，进入时尚界，然后被迫回家并正视她那白人底层根源的故事。片尾有一场婚礼场景，女主角不得不向她大城市的未婚夫解释，她为了那 earthy（淳朴）、 down home（家乡）的高中恋人离开了他。
(SUBJECT) REESE WITHERSPOON AS MELANIE SMOOTER: The truth is I gave my heart away a long time ago, my whole heart, and I never really got it back. And I don't even know what else to say, but I'm sorry. I can't marry you.
瑞茜·威瑟斯彭饰演梅兰妮·斯穆特：事实是我很久以前就把心交出去了，我的整颗心，我从未真正拿回来。我不知道还能说什么，对不起。我不能嫁给你。
Into the stunned silence that follows walks Candice Bergen as the jilted fiance's dragon lady of a mother, who coincidentally also happens to be the mayor of New York. After a volley of insults, Witherspoon decks Bergen.
在随后的死寂中，坎迪斯·伯根饰演被抛弃的未婚夫的“龙妈”，她碰巧也是纽约市长，走了进来。在一阵侮辱之后，威瑟斯彭痛扁了伯根。
[CROWD GASPING]
[观众惊呼]
And it was at this moment, somewhere between when Witherspoon drawled, "Nobody talks to my mama like that," and her father, Earl Smooter raised his face to the heavens and declared, "Praise the Lord, the South has risen again," that something began to happen to me.
就在那一刻，在威瑟斯彭拖着嗓音说出“没人能那样跟我妈说话”之后，她的父亲厄尔·斯穆特面向苍天宣告“赞美上帝，南方再次崛起”之间，某种东西开始发生在我身上。
My face got hot and constricted. A softball rose in my throat that required a surprisingly loud snort to choke back. My breathing grew rapid. In short, I lost it and started to cry.
我的脸发烫收紧。喉咙里冒出一个球，需要用力哼一声才能忍住。呼吸变得急促。简而言之，我失控了，开始哭泣。
I should say that Sweet Home Alabama is not a very good movie. It's actually a pretty terrible movie. I have no particular attachment to Reese Witherspoon, and I'm not from the South. Also, this was the fourth time I'd seen it.
我得说，《情归阿拉巴马》不是一部好电影。其实是一部相当糟糕的电影。我对瑞茜·威瑟斯彭没什么特别的感情，我也不来自南方。而且，这已经是我第四次看它了。
See, my name is Brett, and I cry at movies on airplanes. Not sometimes, always. And not some movies, all movies. Don't believe me? Here's a by no means complete list-- Bend It Like Beckham , 101 Dalmatians , What a Girl Wants , Daredevil .
听着，我叫布雷特，我会在飞机上看电影时哭。不是有时，是总是。不是某些电影，是所有电影。不信？这里有一份绝对不完整的清单——《我爱贝克汉姆》、《101忠狗》、《女孩要什么》、《夜魔侠》。
Let me be clear. I am not afraid of flying. I like flying. And I'm not a crier, at least not on land. Like many men I know, even sensitive ones who know that having a cry can be healthy and good, I passed some invisible line in adolescence when I simply stopped doing it. There  have been many times in life that I probably should have cried, actually tried to cry and wasn't able to-- because, of course, I didn't happen to be at 30,000 feet.
说清楚。我不怕坐飞机。我喜欢飞行。我不是个爱哭鬼，至少在地面上不是。像我认识的许多男人一样，即使是那些知道哭一场对健康有好处的敏感男人，我在青春期跨过了一条看不见的界线，之后就简单地不再哭了。生命中有很多次我本该哭，甚至试过要哭但没能成功——因为，当然，我碰巧不在三万英尺的高空。
Needless to say, this can be embarrassing. I once confessed my problem to a friend, and he thought for a long moment before saying, I'm sorry to hear that. Does it make your mascara run? Earlier this year, I was flying from Denver to New York and found myself seated next to a big, burly guy with a cowboy shirt and a Western belt buckle. Before takeoff, we talked about football or college basketball or something. Then they announced the movie. It was Under the Tuscan Sun . I glanced at my macho new buddy, thought about watching Diane Lane experience love and loss while rediscovering her inner strength in a farmhouse in the Italian countryside, and read the SkyMall catalog instead.
不用说，这很尴尬。我曾经向朋友坦白过我的问题，他思考了很久才说，很抱歉听到这个。那会弄花你的睫毛膏吗？今年早些时候，我从丹佛飞往纽约，发现自己坐在一个穿着牛仔衬衫、带着西部皮带扣的魁梧家伙旁边。起飞前，我们谈论足球、大学篮球之类的。然后广播开始了电影。是《托斯卡纳艳阳下》。我瞥了一眼我那阳刚的新伙伴，想到要看着黛安·莲恩在意大利乡村农舍重新发现内心力量的同时经历爱情和失去，于是我看了看天空购物目录。
For a long time, I thought I was alone in this. And then a few months ago, I was at a party and overheard another guest describe how he fell to pieces watching an episode of Everybody Loves Raymond on a flight to California. I started asking around and found I wasn't completely alone. Greg is a 32-year-old guy in jeans and a Mets hat who just finished writing a book about college sports.
很长一段时间，我以为只有我一个人这样。然后几个月前，我在一个聚会上无意中听到另一位客人描述他在飞往加州的飞机上看《人人都爱雷蒙德》的一集时是如何崩溃的。我开始四处打听，发现我并不孤单。格雷格是一个32岁，穿着牛仔裤戴着大都会队帽子的家伙，刚写完一本关于大学体育的书。
I think it might have been the only movie available was Dirty Dancing II: Havana Nights . The parents watch them dance, and they see how special that this relationship is. And at that moment, they've gone from angry parents to sort of accepting of Javier. I mean, I got choked up.
我想可能唯一能看的电影是《辣身舞2：哈瓦那之夜》。父母看着他们跳舞，他们看到这种关系有多特别。那一刻，他们从愤怒的父母变成了某种接受哈维尔的状态。我的意思是，我哽咽了。
As my fellow leaders will tell you, even not watching the movie is no guarantee of safety. Here's my friend Lindsey.
正如我的同伴们会告诉你的，即使不看电影也不是安全的保障。这是我的朋友琳赛。
So I was on a flight, I believe California to New York. The specifics don't really stand out. But I do remember that it required a $2 deposit for earphones or something, and I wasn't ready to pay the $2, or I didn't have $2. And I decided I'd read my book.
有一次我在飞行中，大概是从加州到纽约。具体的细节不怎么记得了。但我确实记得它需要2美元作为耳机押金之类的，而我没准备好付那2美元，或者我身上没2美元。所以我决定看我的书。
But the movie is playing. And I see it, and I can't take my eyes off of it. So I end up watching the entire duration of the movie without sound. And at various points throughout it, I started welling up, thinking, wow, I can't believe I'm crying at a movie I can't hear the sound to. And it's Freaky Friday .
但电影在播放。我看到了，视线移不开。所以我最终在没声音的情况下看完了整部电影。在整个过程的不同点，我开始涌出泪水，心里想，哇，我不敢相信我竟然会对一部听不到声音的电影哭。那是《辣妈辣妹》。
Or take Stephen, an avid film festival goer and a professional movie critic who can discourse at length on the differences between early and late period Kurosawa. His plane hadn't even taken off.
或者拿斯蒂芬来说，一个热衷于电影节的资深影评人，他能长篇大论地谈论黑泽明早期和晚期的区别。他的飞机甚至还没起飞。
And they were just running this loop of commercials and in-flight programming and stuff. They hadn't started the movie. It was very early on.
他们正在循环播放商业广告和机上节目之类的东西。电影还没开始。时间非常早。
And there was this Amex commercial. A man traveling through Europe, and I think it was nighttime. I want to say it was raining or something. And this kind of haggard traveler, this businessman, is walking briskly through the street. And then they close up on a wallet, clearly his, that he had left behind unknowingly.
有一个美国运通的广告。一个在欧洲旅行的男人，我想那是晚上。我想说在下雨或者什么。然后这个疲惫的旅行者，这个商人，正轻快地走在街上。然后镜头特写到一个钱包，显然是他的，他不知情地落下了。
And then you see it kind of cut to the hotel where he's checking in. And the woman asks for a credit card, and then he pats himself down and realizes he doesn't have it. He goes into a state of panic. I think that's when I started choking up.
然后你看到镜头切到他正在入住的酒店。那个女人问他要信用卡，他摸了摸自己，意识到没有。他陷入了恐慌。我想那就是我开始哽咽的时候。
And then he gets American Express on the phone. They explain that it'll be OK. He'll have a credit card in the morning. And then I start to relax a little bit. And then he says, wait, I'm not going to be in this city. Tomorrow I have to travel. And then I started choking up again.
然后他给美国运通打了电话。他们解释说没关系。他早上就会拿到信用卡。我开始放松一点。然后他说，等等，我不会在那个城市。明天我必须旅行。然后我再次哽咽了。
And then they said, oh, we'll have it waiting for you in that city. And then I just started crying after that. I was so happy for him and relieved. And it was a pretty tense situation there for about 15 or 20 seconds.
然后他们说，噢，我们会让它在你去的那个城市等你。在那之后我就开始哭了。我为他感到如此开心和宽慰。那在那儿持续了大约15到20秒相当紧张的状况。
This is one of the strange features of our problem. We're less likely to cry at the sad parts of a movie-- or financial services industry commercial-- than at the happy ones, the parts where everything turns out all right. For instance, in the movie Larger Than Life , which I saw somewhere over the Atlantic a few years ago, it wasn't the moment when Bill Murray is separated from the elephant that his dead, circus clown father has left him as a means to change his life as a down on his luck motivational speaker that had me reaching for the tissues. It was when they were reunited.
这是我们问题的奇怪特征之一。我们不太可能因为电影——或金融服务业广告——的悲伤部分而哭，反而是为快乐的部分，即一切都好转的时候。例如，在电影《Larger Than Life》中，几年前我曾在北大西洋某处看过，让我伸手拿纸巾的时刻，并不是比尔·默瑞与那头他死去的马戏团小丑父亲留给他的、用来改变他作为落魄励志演说家生活的“遗产”——那头大象分开的时候。而是他们重聚的时候。
In fact, the first time this happened to me was during one of the happiest scenes I'd ever seen. It was in Big Night , Stanley Tucci's movie about paternal love and Italian food. Midway through the movie, Tucci's character and his brother stage a feast in their New Jersey restaurant and at one point bring out a whole roast pig.
事实上，我第一次发生这种情况是在我见过最快乐的场景之一。那是在《大夜》中，斯坦利·图齐关于父爱和意大利食物的电影。电影中段，图齐饰演的角色和他哥哥在他们新泽西的餐厅里精心策划了一场盛宴，并在某个时刻拿出了一整只烤猪。
The camera pans across the faces of the guests, just amazed by this unbelievable bounty being wheeled into the room, and a lump began to rise in my throat. I found myself brimming over with joy, with the sense that somewhere in the darkness miles below, just like on the screen, people were laughing, communing, sharing a meal. It was impossibly beautiful, and there was just nothing to do but cry.
摄像机掠过客人们的脸庞，他们只是惊叹于这运进房间、难以置信的丰盛食物，一个肿块开始在我的喉咙里升起。我发现自己充满了喜悦，意识到在下方几英里的黑暗中，就像银幕上一样，人们在欢笑、交流、分享一顿餐。那简直美得不可思议，除了哭，什么也做不了。
I've never heard of anyone crying inappropriately on trains or on buses or in boats or cars. What is it about airplanes?
我从来没听说过有人在火车、巴士、船或汽车上不合时宜地哭泣。飞机到底是怎么回事？
I remember getting off the plane thinking, I should really actually be embarrassed by the fact that I just cried during Freaky Friday and I didn't even hear the sound to it, but I wasn't. It's like, what happens in the air stays in the air, I guess.
我记得下飞机时心想，我真的应该为自己在《辣妈辣妹》中哭泣甚至连声音都听不到这一事实感到尴尬，但我没有。就像，空中发生的事就留在空中，我猜。
The people I talked to offered a lot of excuses. It's the recirculated air, your eyes are dry, you're often tired and leaving people behind, and of course, there's the obvious conclusion-- we're all scared to death. But I've been on hundreds of planes, including quite a few tiny ones, one sea plane that landed on water, and one blimp. I've taken the controls of a plane. I've jumped out of a plane. I've searched my soul, and honest to God, I find no fear of flying. And all the frequent criers I interviewed felt the same.
我采访的人提出了很多借口。那是循环空气，你的眼睛干了，你通常很累，把人留在后面，当然，还有明显的结论——我们都吓得要死。但我坐过数百次飞机，包括不少小型飞机，一架降落在水面上的水上飞机，还有一个飞艇。我操作过飞机。我从飞机上跳下来过。我审视了自己的灵魂，坦白说，我确实不觉得怕坐飞机。而我采访的所有频繁哭泣的人都有同感。
No, something else happens up there in that weird hanging state between where you're going and where you've left, where there's no phone calls to take, nowhere to go, nothing to do. Some strange overhead compartment of the heart opens up, and critical judgment grabs its flotational seat cushion and follows a lighted pathway to the big yellow slide.
不，在高空那种奇怪的“悬挂状态”下，在你去的地方和你离开的地方之间，没有电话要接，无处可去，无事可做，发生了别的事。心脏的某个奇怪的头顶行李舱打开了，理性判断抓起救生座垫，顺着照明通道滑向了黄色大滑梯。
My friend Greg says this actually makes the ride better. Think about it. You're stuck in a seat for five or 10 or 15 hours, and how would you rather pass the time-- sitting there being a critic or just simply giving in?
我的朋友格雷格说这实际上让旅程变得更好。想想看。你被困在座位上5、10或15小时，你更愿意怎么打发时间——坐在那里当个评论家，还是干脆顺其自然？
I mean, I wouldn't have watched Havana Nights in the waiting area, waiting to get on the plane. On earth, no, not a chance. But once you step on the plane, I'm open to and accepting the movie. And then once you do that, it's going to leave me jelly, turn me into jelly.
我的意思是，我不会在候机区等候登机时看《哈瓦那之夜》。在地面上，不，绝无可能。但一旦你踏上飞机，我就开放并接受电影了。一旦你那样做，它就会让我软化，把我变成“果冻”。
My own theory goes something like this. My father once told me that the reason squirrels get hit by cars is that evolutionarily, nothing in their little hard-wired brains is capable of understanding a large object hurtling toward them at 70 miles per hour. Well, even though I fly all the time, nothing in my little hard-wired brain is capable of understanding-- I mean, really understanding-- stepping onto a metal tube, hanging in space for a while, and then stepping off 6,000 miles away, in a place with different weather, different stars, different time.
我自己的理论是这样的。我父亲曾经告诉我，松鼠被汽车撞的原因是，从进化角度看，它们那微小的大脑里没有什么能理解一个巨大的物体以每小时70英里的速度向它们冲过来。嗯，尽管我经常坐飞机，但我那微小的大脑里没有什么能理解——我的意思是，真正理解——走上一根金属管，在空间里悬挂一会儿，然后6000英里外走下，在一个有不同天气、不同星星、不同时间的地点。
It puts you into a kind of sterile, infantalizing, travel purgatory. You're strapped in, given a blanket, a little sippy cup and tiny silverware, forced to do whatever you're told and borne away at speeds you can't conceive without seeing where you're going. We all deal with this dislocation differently. Many times I thought, why can't I just have air rage? Why can't I be the guy drinking 14 mini bottles of Amaretto, surfing down the aisle on the dinner cart, groping stewardesses and cursing? But then, I do a lot of yelling and screaming down here on the ground, even a little groping.
它把你放进了一种无菌的、婴儿化的、旅行的“炼狱”。你被绑住，给了一条毯子、一个小吸杯和微小的餐具，被迫服从命令，被以你无法想象的速度带走，却看不到你要去哪里。我们所有人以不同方式应对这种错位。很多次我心想，为什么我不能直接有“飞行暴怒”？为什么我不能是那个喝掉14个小瓶阿玛雷托酒，在餐车上滑行，猥亵空姐并咒骂的家伙？但话说回来，我在地面上大吼大叫过很多次，甚至还猥亵过。
What I don't do is cry, not over breakups or reunions or triumphs or deaths or leaving home or coming back or any of life's other bumps and transformations. And maybe that's the key to my air-- what, sorrow? Maybe I cry the tears I should be shedding on earth.
我不做的是哭泣，不是因为分手、重逢、胜利或死亡，或离开家或回来，或生命中任何其他的碰撞和转变。也许这就是我空中——什么，忧伤？的秘密。也许我哭的是我本该在地球上流下的眼泪。
And all you people who don't cry on airplanes, you're probably the ones I see sobbing on the subway or on street corners or at funerals. You probably get it all out at home. Well, boo hoo. Do us all a favor and keep it in the air, you babies.
而你们那些不在飞机上哭的人，你们可能是那些我在地铁上或街角或葬礼上看到呜咽的人。你们可能在家里就把情绪释放完了。好吧，“呜呜”。帮大家一个忙，在空中释放吧，你们这些宝宝。
Brett Martin is a correspondent for GQ and the author of book about hit TV shows, Difficult Men: Behind the Scenes of a Creative Revolution .
布雷特·马丁是《GQ》的一名记者，也是关于热门电视剧《困难男人：创意革命幕后》一书的作者。
[MUSIC - MIDDLE CLASS FASHION, "STUCK"]
[音乐 - 中产阶级时尚，《Stuck》]
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Simon Adler. Our story about Rachel and her vegetarian son was co-produced with Julian Gunther.
嗯，我们今天的节目由乔纳森·门吉瓦制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼格、米基·米克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。西蒙·阿德勒提供了制作帮助。我们关于蕾切尔和她素食儿子的故事是与朱利安·冈瑟共同制作的。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Research help today from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米莉·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的办公室经理。今天的研究帮助来自米歇尔·哈里斯和朱莉·比尔。音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I was just thinking about this the other how young he and I both were. We were so young when we made the deal to start the radio. And we had that woman, a lawyer, helping us, and we were both so strong headed. I have a recording.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》通过PRX（公共广播交换）传送给公共广播电台。和往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，我刚才在想，他和我都曾多么年轻。我们开始制作这个广播时是多么年轻。我们有那个女人，一个律师，帮助我们，我们两个都那么固执。我有个录音。
Fine. It starts on Saturday.
好的。从周六开始。
All right, good. But can you guys shake on it? I think this is interesting.
好的，很好。你们能握手言和吗？我觉得这很有意思。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。